ce que l'on appelle aujourd'hui les
terroristes n'ont pas entendu l'appel au
cessez le feu lancé cet après-midi par
le comité de salut national ces
miliciens qui formaient l'armé
personnelle pour étendirent de chaouch
et ce coût se bat non seulement pour
tenter de sauver leur peau mais ils
veulent encore semer la terreur nous
avons tous encore en mémoire le charnier
de timisoara la ville d'où est partie la
révolte roumaine il continue en s'en
prenant à tout ce qui bouge tirent sur
la foule mitraille dans les immeubles et
même sur les hôpitaux
le reportage qui va suivre leproux on
touche là au comble de l'horreur hervé
brusini au coeur de bucarest
la monstruosité tant bien que mal ses
miliciens protège cet hôpital de secours
car dehors on leur tire dessus
on est même venu massacrait jusque dans
ce bâtiment venez regarder dit le
médecin
lui c'est un terroriste il hommes en
blanc certainement la securitate et la
garde prétorienne de ceausescu
certains d'entre eux disent les témoins
étaient drogués près assassiné tout ce
qui bouge
il y a là une centaine de camps où se
mêlent tueur et victimes des combats de
rue
certains ont été tuées au sein même de
l'hôpital
ça fait plus de 20 ans je suis médecin
légiste même à l'époque du tremblement
de terre j'ai pas vu ça j'ai jamais vu
une telle boucherie chine où vas tu en
as tu es on a fusillé même ici à
l'hôpital
ils ont tiré de ce côté et de ce côté
aussi de l'hôpital j'aurais jamais pu
imaginer une telle chose j'aurais jamais
cru que des êtres humains soient
capables d'une telle chose jamais été
discret ce soir c'est noël d'une
journaliste ya pas longtemps je savais
encore un poème qui disait je te prie
toi bon et juste seigneur sauve mon pays
et mon peuple pour la roumanie libre à
bucarest les combats entre armée forces
de sécurité ont fait plus de 5000 morts
aujourd'hui les médecins roumains manque
de tout plasma sans calment anesthésique
seringue
à l'extérieur un homme des forces
patriotiques montent la garde devant des
cercueils
devant l'horreur